derek scuba on the year
one and six whip at one five three so
he's getting a lot of base runners
opponents hitting 260. the east will
lead off cesar hernandez
and the pitch is swung on hit high hit
deep to left back is grossman and this
ball is gone
over the bullpen and into the seats and
left and
cesar hernandez with his sixth home run
as he leads off tonight's game blasting
the second pitch
of the game into the seats in left field
here's the 3-2 swung on him missed
first out is a strikeout for terrex
scuba
another 2-2 swung out and missed
back-to-back punch-outs for scuba here
in the first
little extra for him didn't he now the
1-1
to center field but due got a late jump
but he catches up to it
well aaron savage he is making his 10th
start seven
times he has pitched uh excuse me five
times out of the nine starts he has
pitched
seven innings he is six and one three
thirty this is the third time he's
matched up against tariq skubal this
year
there it is he started that off the
plate
that thing ended up right in the heart
of the dish
and i think grossman sort of gave up on
it yeah looked away and you didn't
realize it came right over the middle
yeah and it's swung on lifted high in
the air to center
drifting back is luplow but that's death
valley out there
he'll make the grab candelario is out
number two
castro still at first indians still up
one nothing
that would seem to be an easy one to get
right
savali works the scoreless first one
nothing cleveland after an inning
then you see him a couple times and try
and make it tougher on him
2-2 he struck him out
already a third strikeout for tarik
skubal
the 2-2 swung on and missed another
punch out for tarik skubal
make it four and two in a row here in
the second
now the one-two struck him out he
strikes out the side
one two smashed into the ground for jim
candelario
went away you see this young man ramirez
swing late on the fastball you know it's
good
the o2 fastball 96 above the strike zone
the 2-2
second time that he struck out lukewarm
tonight
in on his hands popped it up is it
playable yes sir
one away jose ramirez has that
jake rogers with a liner and it's caught
by a med rosario or did he short hop
short hop either way it's two outs
and that's caught by owen miller to
retire the side
three complete from motown one nothing
cleveland
[Music]
that's a thing of beauty right down the
chalk kicks off the sidewall though
and that'll keep eddie from scoring but
the indians have
the beginnings of a rally second and
third nobody out
with an rabi opportunity for owen miller
got the fastball he'll get his first
big league run battered in it's two to
nothing cleveland
another 2-2 inning over strikes out
hedges for his seventh strikeout of the
night
3-2 pitch strike three gold
that's the same pitch he got strike two
on him
they swung at it and strikes out so he
swung at the first one off the dish he
swung at the last one off the dish on
the 3-2 count
popped up on the infield back in the
second inning
left field eddie inning over
four complete the payoff
he struck him out nasty that's the
slider gibb he was calling for
the 2-2 he sits him down
strikes out luplo for the third time
so once again he's out there doing his
thing
got in on him just enough to keep that
one in the yard one down
willie castro jammed he rolls over on
one and that's what you love i think
he's had about
three outs if not four on one pitch or
less
oh baby four k's for savali
he retires the side in order aaron
savala
has blanked the tigers on three hits he
has struck out four hasn't walked a
matter
deep center loop blow plenty of room
oh that's made for that park use that
center field
area
through the fastball by a little cut
piece
five strikeouts for savali aaron somali
working
on a four-hit shout out
reach for it taps it to bowers and we've
got one away
[Music]
1-0 slam to center that's deep luplow
tracking it and that ball is off the
wall but news got
speed to burn on his way to third he's
in there with a head first slide
that man can motor
and his pitch is swung on hit in the air
to left
and routine caught by rosario and somali
gets out of it seven in the books
on the ground nice play by cabrera and
they get the lead rudder
well done he can still pick it luplow
who has struck out three times tonight
deep center badou bye-bye
how about that luplow with a two-run
homer here in the eighth
and that erases those three strikeouts
earlier
and it builds the indians a four-nothing
lead
he came back with another breaking ball
and
he left it up a little bit and luplow
just saw one he swung
through it but he didn't do it on this
one he hits it out to left center field
and for loop load will be his seventh
homer
it's really been a clinic today on
pitching and how to mix pitches up move
it in and out and keep hitters off
balance
god i am looking with that fastball that
two seamer that starts off the plate
the pitch swung on this is hit pretty
well toward right center but right there
to grab the liner is
harold ramirez out number two
that pitch swung on a one hop smash to
second
miller will throw him out and aaron
savali is
going to get a shot at his first
complete game major league shutout
just a little low ball four tigers get
the first time in the board here in the
ninth
right by him at 98 miles an hour
he didn't mess around with any off speed
pitches right there i'm glad to see that
because he went right at him
the one two jonathan scope sharply hit
and out of the reach to the shortstop
ahmed rosario candelario will be waved
home
he'll score and jonathan scope comes
through with an rbi
single here in the ninth and the indians
now leading it four to one
here in the night bases loaded eric haas
had a chance
last night he's got another shot tonight
[Applause]
another curveball hit in the air center
field
luplow
[Applause]
the indians have won six straight over
the tigers